in Star Trek it's the stuff that powered
the warp drive of the Starship
Enterprise into the 23rd Century take us
out
but antimatter isn't Fiction it's real
and it's one of the greatest puzzles in
our universe that's because there should
be as much of it as normal matter but
physicists can't find reserves of it
anywhere on Earth nor anywhere else in
the cosmos it can only be found in
extremely tiny samples made at
incredible expense here in Earth's
largest particle accelerator the CERN
laboratory of Switzerland so basically
what we want to do with it is to just
make sure that every property that we
know that matter has that anti-matter
has it in the same way or maybe not
because any small difference there could
help us understand what happened with
antimatter in 1928 British mathematician
Paul Durock discovered antimatter in an
equation but whole atoms of antimatter
don't exist for very long and that's
because when they meet normal matter the
two explode with the strongest energy
release known by scientists if both had
been created in equal measure during the
Big Bang the universe Would Have Ended
as soon as it began so there's a big
mystery because half the universe is
gone
so it's an interesting question in
itself
for two decades scientists at CERN have
been making whole antimatter atoms they
want to find out how they work but
mostly they wanted to drop them to see
if they fell upwards opposite gravity's
pull because if they did it would have
thrown physics into crisis it would be a
enormous Revolution it means we don't
understand physics we don't understand
nature at all
after two decades cern's physicists
produced about a hundred millionths of a
gram of anti-hydrogen and tipped a few
dozen into a tube the result they fell
down just like normal matter in physics
you don't really know something until
you observe it so this was the first
attempt to actually observe that what
happens if I drop antimatter in the
gravitational field of the Earth the
answer is as far as we can tell they
drop in the same way to the current
level of precision of this experiment
Galileo Newton and Einstein Vindicated
and no antimatter spaceships for us
anytime soon
Colin Baker Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera